November last year on the luffini land
Reserve in the Republic of the Congo
government ministers to Great Fanfare
launching a high-profile carbon
offsetting project with French oil giant
total energies the aim to plant 40
million trees in the coming decade but
now an investigation by journalists
working for Greenpeace UK Unearthed and
the source material website and shared
exclusively with Sky News suggests the
project has come at a significant cost
for an estimated 400 farmers and their
families who own or use the land
to make way for the tree planting some
say they've been blocked from their
fields without consultation or payment
s
if you are seeing with tractors you are
chased away says Clarice parfait
the crops are not harvested it's to kill
us to send us back to being slaves again
it's left some worrying about feeding
their children
I feel like these people came to kill us
on our own land says
we're not able to go far with our
studies so we gave ourselves to
agriculture I was working the fields to
feed my children and grandchildren
a few well-established families were
paid but not very much the equivalent of
80 Pence per hectare and there doesn't
appear to have been much choice about it
anyway
documents show that by the time some had
accepted money to give up their fields
the government had already changed the
law more than a year earlier to become
the private owner of the luffini reserve
that land then quickly subleased via a
forestry consultancy to Total with
reassurances from the government that
anyone else trying to use it would be
evicted other documents show that after
total's planting scheme began the
ministry of the forest economy
acknowledged in this report a range of
other problems with the project
including complaints from unpaid
families confusion over land rights and
a lack of leadership
the Congolese government declined to
comment total energies and the forestry
consultancy they worked with defended
what they called an ambitious and
pioneering partnership
but in a statement they told Sky News
that they had recently launched an
assessment this will they said establish
a complete picture of those who are
affected by the project and will
identify a remediation action plan
including livelihood restoration
measures that comply with International
standards results will be complete and
made public in 2023
this project just won a parent example
of the human cost of offsetting
vulnerable people seemingly the most at
risk in a rapidly growing and almost
unregulated Global carbon Market
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News